they are so
desperate to defend abortion that the
libs are really shooting themselves in
the foot
it's a this is my favorite version of it
a woman
this is being reported in the dallas
morning news
a pregnant woman says her fetus should
count as a passenger in hov lanes
she got a ticket anyway when she got
pulled over they say the the overturning
of roe v wade
has one driver questioning hov lane laws
requiring two passengers in a car yeah
take that conservatives take that
conservative you think
you think that a baby is really a baby
well if that's the case
then maybe
pregnant women should be allowed to
drive in the carpool lane you know the
corporal lanes that we libs invented and
that are really a nuisance and mess up
traffic and we invented them because
we're worried about global warming which
you conservatives don't really care
about at all and probably don't believe
in you know that so we're gonna what are
you saying what the lives are saying is
that in order to try to own the cons
when it comes to abortion they're going
to
effectively abolish carpool lanes right
because if
if if a pregnant woman can ride in the
carpool lane then really any woman could
plausibly drive in the carpool lane
because any woman could say that she's
pregnant and it's just not showing yet
so they're willing to abolish the stupid
hov lanes which conservatives already
don't like
in order to
try to point out some hypocrisy or
something on abortion no i think it's
great i think pregnant women absolutely
should drive in the carpool lane
i think all women should drive in the
carpool lane
i think everybody should drive in the
carpool lane this is the same sort of
thing you see when the libs will say oh
yeah you think that a baby is a human
being well maybe we should pass laws
requiring men who impregnate women
to take care of them from the moment of
conception
great sounds good cool so we should make
it harder
for men and women to break up when they
have a kid together we should we should
encourage marriage is what you're saying
and discourage divorce
and encourage people to have ever more
normal family structures cool sounds
good
i'm in sign me up
well
if you think that a baby
is really a baby maybe we should support
giving special tax benefits i actually
saw this there was a prominent liberal
account on twitter last night who said
we should give we should give
tax benefits to
pregnant women
and and men you know in families who who
have a baby on the way
uh we should allow those those people to
count the baby in the womb as a
dependent
oh no
please don't you're telling me we have
to defend life and you're gonna cut
specifically my taxes oh no you know
conservatives who we famously hate tax
cuts
right so the limbs are trying anything
and they're throwing spaghetti at the
wall here and they keep getting more and
more frustrated because all of the all
of the proposals that they're making to
try to show our hypocrisy are proposals
that we actually like and it shows you
something that we've pointed out on the
show a lot a lot in the past which is
conservatives basically understand what
the libs believe the libs really have no
idea what conservatives believe and you
see this nowhere more clearly than on
pro-life on the issue of life the libs
truly believe that pro-lifers just we
hate women we don't really care about
babies we don't really think the baby in
the womb is a baby but we just hate
women and we want to control their
bodies and that's not it's just not true
i know that they believe that but it's
just not true and so all of their
attempts to refute our arguments and own
us and and dismantle our political
program all it's ever going to do is
shoot them in the foot they are smacking
their own nose despite their face and
they're bolstering the pro-life side
works for me i'm feeling much more
comfortable these days right now head on
over to tuvu.com knowles we are facing a
mental health crisis it is directly
linked to big tech social media
platforms we all love social media we're
all on social media that's how we live
today that's the public square
problem is these platforms are designed
to addict you to likes the affirmation
of others they are not good for us for
our minds or for our spirits they're
funded by advertising that for the first
time in history is tailored specifically
and individually for you what's the goal
the goal is to cater to your every whim
whether those whims are edifying or
destructive every whim that they think
will make you give them more of your
time and money thankfully there is a new
social media app that breaks the mold of
the advertising based model designed
with your best interests in mind and
based on connection not addiction that
is to vu the social app where you can
share what matters to you by offering a
membership-based platform built on
family values and freedom tuvu makes it
possible for you to have a guilt-free
social media experience have you been
looking for a social media platform that
will allow you to get back to basics you
just want to share pictures of your
family and your friends and maybe the
occasional meme without all that toxic
sludge that comes on the other platforms
well head on over to tuvu
it's super super simple to sign up you
download tuvu you try it free for seven
days then it's just 299 a month it's not
a lot of money it's a little bit of
money and when you think about those
free quote unquote social media
platforms they ain't so free they're
costing money in other ways go to
tuvu.com knowles or look for the tuvu
app on google play or the app store and
remember to follow me at michael j
knowles
a woke lady soldier in the u.s army is
questioning her loyalty to america
in the wake of the dobb's decision
overruling roe v wade
it happened
it happened
i woke up from a nap to this
on deployment i woke up from a nap to
this news
america is waking up to this news
i just extended my contract
to continue serving this country a week
ago
how am i supposed to swear to support
and defend
the constitution
and a country
that treats its women
like
second-class citizens
how am i supposed to do that how am i
supposed to do that with pride
how am i supposed to do that with love
and honor
how am i supposed to wake up every day
and put on a freaking uniform that says
united states army when the united
states doesn't even give a rat's ass
about me
i don't know guess you gotta leave
i love this woman is threatening she's
implicitly threatening to leave the army
i'm not how am i supposed to serve
howard
how are you to expect us liberal woke
women to serve in the army conservatives
oh i guess we can buy
guess you have to leave then
is that a threat or a promise darling
don't threaten me with a good time get
out we don't want you in the army we
don't i don't the woman is questioning
her loyalty to america well while
wearing or she's not wearing in that
video i guess she's got it in her closet
or something a u.s army uniform don't
don't do me any favors get out i don't
want you in the army
that's fine the kicker of course is
she's posting her treasonous nonsense on
tick tock on a chinese spy app get out
of the army we don't want you there go
away
she should be fired of course
it's not just that she should be
permitted to quit if you
question your loyalty to the united
states of america
over killing babies or for any other
reason
over america not letting you kill enough
babies or for any other reason
and you do so on a chinese spy app
get out you should be fired she should
probably be court-martialed she should
at the very least be let go go into
private life go away go away please
this is another example of the of the
libs not getting what we want
conservatives fought women in combat
positions we didn't fight the women we
fought putting women in combat positions
because it's extremely disordered and
it's not good for a country to do that
and because the army is not about our
individual rights the army is about
protecting the country and sometimes we
have to
to to suppress our own individual
desires for the greater good of
protecting the country which is the
whole point of the army we fought that
and until very very recently
conservatives still don't like the idea
and now this liberal woman is saying
yeah no i'm well maybe i'll leave the
army good oh no
this is just like the car lane thing or
the liberals
encouraging marriage as a response to to
the overruling of roe v wade or
encouraging chastity or encouraging any
of these things they think we're gonna
we're gonna protest that we're gonna
fight back we're not gonna fight back
that's what we want get out compare this
lady by the way
to a retired
general retired three i think he's a
three-star general retired lieutenant
general gary valesky
who was serving as a highly qualified
expert senior mentor
he was just suspended from the military
and he was suspended
from the military for posting a
generally
polite
really innocuous kind of joking tweet to
jill biden joe biden tweeted out also on
this roe v wade issue said for nearly 50
years women have had the right to make
our own decisions about our bodies today
that right was stolen from us so it's
joe biden whining about how
american women can't kill quite as many
babies anymore and
this general didn't even have a
political dispute with her and he didn't
say anything insulting he just responded
and said glad to see you finally know
what a woman is
because the libs have been saying for
years we don't know what a woman is what
is a woman matt made his whole movie
about it and then the minute that roe v
wade gets overruled all of a sudden they
figure out what a woman is and then the
general actually deleted the tweet
doesn't matter he's been suspended from
the military
for for making a lighthearted joke
about the political controversy
surrounding the very definition of the
word woman meanwhile this woke chickie
in the army gets to say i might not be
loyal to america anymore and she gets to
keep her job does that make any sense
no
no it doesn't make any sense until you
realize
that there are two tracks of justice
here
there are two tracks of justice there's
justice
there's justice injustice really in both
tracks but there's going to be one
system of punishment for conservatives
who transgress liberal orthodoxy and
there's going to be another track
for the liberals and it's not going to
be punishment very often it's going to
be a reward if if i went out into the
street right now and started punching
people and stealing nike shoes out of
store fronts and tossing molotov
cocktails i would be thrown in prison
for a very very long time
if blm goes out and does the same thing
kamala harris will bail them out of jail
they will get a slap on the wrist if
that they'll probably have their charges
dismissed so that they're ready to go
back out in the streets and commit acts
of terror for the next left-wing cause
du jour
that's what it's really about
so
the woke lady goes out and whines and
screams and says i might not be loyal to
my country
i
doubt she'll be punished
and yet this general makes a joke
lightly questioning transgenderism he's
going to be suspended his career is
totally over
i'm glad you like that clip now hold up
i'm about to hit a million i'm very
close to a million youtube's probably
going to nuke my account at that point
that's fine whatever let's accelerate it
baby ring ding wamalama dingdong click
that bell subscribe get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]